now I'm ready to ask this question about
what about the extremity was like I see
this is the farthest in I can go right
there those it disaster I'm doing
something out here clearly and the
question is what am i doing out there so
I'm interested in what happens as X
approaches infinity since it's
symmetrical that will tell me what
happens as X approaches negative
infinity does that make sense okay so if
have a look at the board even everything
that's written on the board which of the
things on the board is gonna be most
helpful to try and determine what is
this behaving like as X approaches
infinity
take some minutes right yeah
why which one each is when there's lines
- this one yeah this one
I can't sleep in the sky
I think this is a great candidate and
the reason why because when I'm trying
to work out
let's give us simply tip so if I'm going
to say well what's the limit as X
approaches infinity of like 2 to the Nu
minus X right
in other words I'm trying to say we
would exist doing something so what's
the whole thing doing so in here how
could work out what X is doing that I
can write now that the whole thing is do
that's good so are you going to try and
investigate the limit as X approaches
infinity of 1 and this is what Y is
okay so exist
so it should be like what
yes sorry yes this is [ __ ]
okay now stay with me at this per second
okay
how about look at the terms you got on
these three x squared and negative
twelve now remember I'm going left to
infinity right infinity okay so what do
you what does your intuition tell you
you will happen to this negative twelve
million he's going to become so tiny I
can pretty much ignore him right okay so
just for a second now look at this time
now look at that
what does your intuition we're gonna do
this rigorously in a second but I wanna
I want to guide our reader a rigorous
approach but I think about it in to you
what do you think is gonna happen to
that as X approaches infinity
you've got the sweet root of a-square
number right slavery to slant so
therefore you're gonna get that number
right that's linear behavior does that
make sense as X approaches infinity that
thing is going to encourage you from the
kind of roughly the same rate
the only thing kind of throwing us off
is that root three okay and because it's
multiplying through it's not adding or
subtracting it kind of gets bigger as
well right okay let me show you how I'm
going to demonstrate its algebraic has
got some intuition now I'm going to
factorize out 3x squared from underneath
DM square roots up like this
plus the cement the square root of
I just
now if i factor out 3x squared it seems
like a weird thing to factor out because
I'm going to introduce some denominators
but actually so no man is a kind of
exactly what I want because denominators
limits make mincemeat of denominators
right that's their whole thing okay so
what happens when I take out 3x squared
because the 3 is cancelled with them
like this is why there's a 4 up there
okay I'm just gonna get x squared sorry
yeah you've done the 3 twice okay look
at that for a second look carefully at
it as I go to the next step hmm
this is the product of two things
automate the square root we can break
them apart never worries with breaking
them upon this is giving plus or minus
square root of 3x squared
1-1 excellent
okay now he was the previous step this
is why factorizing was so good of course
then if I know that this is on the
denominator and it's protein zero what
happens in this guy it disappears right
so that's me trying to take I know this
thing is going to disappear that 12 that
you told me was going to be
insignificant so I need to get it in a
form that makes that hard to break the
obvious so I divided through by X / 3 x
squared so now I'm actually gonna
evaluate this limit what happens to this
whole thing that whole square root as X
approaches infinity 1 it goes to 1 or
more specifically 1 minus 0 squared 4
minus 2 which of course is 1 so
therefore you're just getting this guy
right plus or minus the square root of 3
X plan right now I'm you guys know that
the square root of a square number is
not just a number it's the absolute
value of it however our plus or minus
hanging out the front which kind of just
invalidates that that absolute value
right so this is just gonna be plus or
minus the square root of 3 X that's what
happens with that experiment breaks out
no please that I've I mean or he
actually died because the possum is kind
of over
what does this mean what are we trying
to find in the first place
yeah good it behavior extremities we
were looking for some mom some limiting
banging jump now I know it may be him
here it is I've got two divides not one
but two right root 3x it would be
something like this my pastas through
the Orangemen kind of like climbing like
root 3 is 1.7 that's like has that kind
of slant and minus root 3 X why is that
there what's going on with that guy why
does he even exist why do I have two of
big asymptotes
Jenny graves I've got this symmetry
right like as X gets bigger I'm not just
approaching six I'm also going to
negative six I'm going off like that so
that's why I have this opposite facing
okay this is looking really good
I know that - - - that's outside the
domain
everything else is spending I know I'm
here and whatever I do here has to be
symmetrical that way right and I've got
to get to these asymptotes yeah I can
only think that one thing that's gonna
do it's gonna go up to what that hasn't
turned like so and it's gonna go down to
that hasn't I'm like so you've got that
vertical centering happening and because
it's an even thing we can tell you about
it because it has even cemetery
cylinders saving over here
it's a relation right
here is a shape and yes we know a name
for this shape this is called a mother
of 4 is greater than 1 this shape is the
hacker
and it's a thing of beauty
now we took a lot of time to develop
that okay as you go through we're gonna
start to recognize speeches and we're
not obviously gonna like this is
everything is from scratch this is like
I've never seen it before
however if I work with this thing